the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so I'd like to pick up again on the
ion this neat family of matrices
circulant matrices but first let me say
here and then put it on the web my
thought about the projects so I think
the last deadline and I can give is the
final class so I think that's not next
week but Wednesday of the following week
I think is our last class meeting so be
great to get them then or earlier and if
anybody or everybody would like to tell
the class a little bit about their
project you know it's a friendly
audience and and I'd be happy to make
space and time for that so so send me an
email if you or and and give me the
project earlier if you would like to
just say a few words in class or even if
you are willing to say a few words in
class I'll say yeah because I realize
yeah okay so other questions about so so
we're finished with all p-sets and so on
so it's really just a project and yeah
how is it graded good question but it's
going to be me
I guess so so I'll read all the projects
and come up with a grade somehow you
know I my I hope you guys have
understood that I'm you know my feeling
is that the grades in this course are
going to be on the high side because
they should be yeah I think it's a it's
that kind of a course and I'm asked you
for to do a fair amount and anyway
that's my starting basis and there's a
lot of topics like circulant matrices
that I'm not going to be able to give
you a piece set about but I of course
these are closely can
that to the discrete Fourier transform
so let me just write the name of the
great man Fourier so the discrete
Fourier transform is as you know very
very important algorithm in in
engineering and in mathematics
everywhere Fourier is just a key idea
and so I think it's just good to know
about those so circulant matrices are
connected with with the finite size
matrices matrices of size and some are
circulant matrices will be n by n and
you remember this special form so this
is a key point about these matrices see
that they are defined by not n squared
entries only n if you tell me just the
first row of the matrix and that's all
you would tell MATLAB say C 0 C 1 C 2 C
and minus 1 and for a circulant that's
all I need to know because these
diagonals are constant this diagonal is
constant C 1 and then gets completed
here C two diagonal come to C 2 and then
gets completed cyclically here so M
numbers and not n squared and that the
reason I mention that or a reason is
that's there that's a big selling point
when you go to applications same machine
learning in for images so you remember
the big picture of machine learning
deep deep learning was that you had
samples
a lot of samples let's say n samples
maybe and then each sample in this image
part will be an image so the thing is
that an image is described by its pixels
and if I have a thousand by thousand
pixel so that's a million a million
pixels it the the feature vector the
vector that's associated with one sample
is enormous is enormous so so so I vents
ampuls but maybe maybe well if they're
in color that million suddenly becomes
three million so say three million
features so our vectors our vector of
that the whole computation of deep
learning works with our vectors with
three million components and that means
that in the ordinary way if we didn't do
anything special we would be multiplying
those by matrices of size like three
million times three million we would be
computing that many weights that's like
impossible that's like and we would be
computing that for for each layer in the
deep network so it would go up a normai
it go up so three million by three
million is just we can't compute we
can't use gradient descent to optimize
that many weight so the point is that
the matrices in deep learning are
special and they don't depend they they
are like circulant matrices they might
not loop around so circulant matrices
have this cyclic feature that that makes
the theory perfect extremely nice
but of course in general we have
matrices let's say T t0 constant
diagonals and maybe bunch of diagonals
in here not necessarily symmetric or
they might be symmetric but they're not
cyclic so what are these matrices called
well they have a bunch of names because
they're so important they're they're
linear shift invariant or linear time
invariant whatever is the right word in
your context so so they're they're
convolutions you could call it a
convolution matrix when they multiply by
one of these matrices I guess I'm going
to call it t you're doing our
convolution and I'll better write down
the formula for our convolution you're
not doing a cyclic convolution unless
the matrix cycles round this would when
you multiply by C this would give you a
cyclic convolution say if I multiply C
by some vector V the result is the
cyclic convolution of the C vector with
the V vector so big C is a matrix but
but it's completely defined by its first
row or first column so it's really I
just have a vector operation there and
it's a cyclic one and over here T times
a vector V will be the convolution of a
T vector with V but not cyclic and
probably these are the ones that would
actually come in to machine learning so
linear shift invariant linear time
invariant
I would call it so mask people would
call it a triplets matrix so that's
that's why I used the letter T in
engineering it would be a filter or a
convolution or are constant diagonal
matrix these come up all sorts of places
and they come up in in machine learning
and with image processing but basically
because what you're doing at one point
in an image it's pretty much what you're
going to do at the other points
you're not gonna figure out special
weights for each little pixel in the
image you're going to take if you have
an image say you have an image with with
zillions of pixels
well you might want to cut down I mean
you'd be very sensible to do some max
pooling some pooling operations to make
it smaller so that's really like okay we
can't we don't want this larger system
let's just reduce it so max pooling that
operation would be say take them three
at a time from nine pixels and replace
that nine pixels by one pixel so the max
of those nine numbers that would be a
very simple operation that just reduces
the dimension that's make it smaller
reduce the dimension
okay so that's a cheap way to make it
make an image for four times or nine
times or 64 times smaller but the
convolution part now so that's not
involving convolution that's a different
operation here not even linear if I take
the max in each box that's not a linear
operation so but it's a fast one okay so
now where do circulant soar convolution
or triplets matrices or filters come
into it so I'll forget about the max
cooling suppose that's happened and I
still have a very big system with N
squared
pixels and squared features in for each
sample so that's so I want to operate on
that by matrices as usual I want to
choose the weights to bring out the
important points so the whole idea is on
a image like that I'll use a convolution
I'll use this the same operation is
happening at each point so if so forget
the max part let me erase if I can find
an eraser here okay so I'm I'm not gonna
we've done this so that's done now I
want to multiply it by weight so that
that's already done okay so what am I
looking to do what was it what kind of a
job would a filter do a low-pass filter
would kill or nearly kill the high
frequencies the noise so if I wanted to
get a simpler image there I would use a
lope
filter which might just it might be this
this filter here with let me just put in
some numbers that would that would say a
half and a half so I'm averaging each
pixel with its neighbor just to take out
some of the high frequencies the low
frequencies are constant image a black
all black image would come out not
changed but a very highly speckled image
would get largely removed by that
averaging so I it's the same idea that
comes up in all of say no processing
filtering so just to complete this
thought of how why does a wider neural
nets so I'm answering this question why
how do they come in machine learning
so they come when when the samples are
images and then it's natural to use a a
constant diagonal matrix a shift
invariant matrix and not an arbitrary
matrix so we're we only have to compute
n weights and not N squared yeah
so that's the point so that's one reason
for talking about convolution and
circulant matrices in this course I
guess I feel another reason is that
everything to do with the DFT with
Fourier it with Fourier and Fourier
transforms and phoria matrices
that's just like stuff you got to know I
mean that's every time you have a you're
dealing with vector
that are sort of shift we're shifting
the vectors comes into it that's for
EA's gonna come in so it's just we
should see for you okay so now can i
I'll go back to this specially nice case
where the where the the matrix loops
around where I have this cyclic
convolution so so this are-- cyclic
because of the looping around stuff and
let's find oh so what was the point of
last time I I started with this
permutation matrix and the permutation
matrix has C 0 equals 0 C 1 equal 1 and
the rest of the C's are 0 so it's just
the effect of multiplying by this get a
box around it here the effect of
multiplying by this permutation matrix
is to shift everything and then bring
the last one up to the top so it's a
cyclic shift so six things sheriff is
outside and I guess at the very end of
last time I was asking about its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors so can we
come to that question so that's a
starting question for everything here I
guess we've understood that too to get
deeper into a matrix its eigenvalues
eigenvectors or singular value singular
vectors are the way to go actually what
would be the singular values of that
matrix so that's uh yeah just lets let's
just think about singular values and
then we'll see why why its eigenvalues
we
saying - they're one of the singular
values of a permutation matrix they're
all one all one that matrix is a
orthogonal matrix so the the SVD of the
matrix just has like the permutation and
then the identity is therefore the Sigma
so Sigma is I for this mate for this
matrix not so the singular values don't
and now I guess if we that's because P
transpose P is the identity matrix
anytime I have that that's an orthogonal
matrix then maybe anytime P transpose P
is the identity the singular values will
be the eigen values of the identity and
that's there they're all just ones the
eigen values of P that's what we want to
find so let's do that
okay eigen values of P so one way is to
take P minus lambda I that's the way we
teach in 1806 and never use again so
it's minus lambda on the diagonal and of
course P is sitting up here and then
okay so now following the 1806 rule I
should take that determinate right and
set it to zero why don't one this is one
of the very few occasions we can
actually do it so allow me to do it so
what is the determinant of this well
yeah there's that there's that lambda to
the fourth and I guess I think it's lamb
to the fourth minus one I think that's
the right determinant
that certainly has has property so I
would set that to zero then I would find
that the the eigenvalues for that will
be one and minus one and I and minus I
and they're the for for if they're the
fourth roots of one lambda the fourth
equal one that's our that's our equation
that's our eigenvalue equation lambda
the fourth equal 1 or lambda to the N
sequel one so what would be the
eigenvalues for for the free p 8x8 this
is the complex plane of course real and
imaginary so that's got a Tigan values
we want to be the 8th power would be the
identity and that means that lambda to
the 8th power is one for the eigenvalues
and what are the eight solutions every
polynomial equation of degree eight has
got to have eight solutions
that's Gauss's fundamental theorem of
algebra eight solutions so what are they
what are the eight numbers whose eighth
power gives one you all probably know
them so they're one of course the eighth
power of one is power of -1 the 8th
power of minus I and the other guys are
just here the roots of one are equally
spaced around the circle so Fourier is
come in
you know Fourier wakes up when they sees
that picture for here is gonna be here
and it'll be in the eigenvectors so
you okay with the eigenvalues the
eigenvalues of p will be this number so
we better give a name to this number
let's see I'm gonna call that number W
and it'll be e to the 2 pi I over 8
right because the angle is 2 pi the
whole angle is 2 pi divided it by in 8
pieces so the that's 2 pi over 8 2 pi
over and for a matrix of four the end by
end permutation yeah so that's number W
and of course this guy is is w squared
this one is WQ w 4 w v 6 7 and w 8 is
the same as 1 right so right well those
the reason I put those numbers up there
is that they come into the eigenvectors
as well as the eigenvalues
they are the eigenvalues these eight
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 are the eight
eigenvalues of the matrix
it's a here's the 4 4 by 4 case the
matrix is an orthogonal matrix Oh what
does that tell us about the eigenvectors
the eigenvectors of an orthogonal matrix
are orthogonal
just like symmetric matrices so do you
know that little list of matrices with
orthogonal eigenvectors so ok I'm going
to call them Q so Q I dotted with Q J
the inner product is
1 or 0 1 if I would say 0 if I is not J
orthogonal eigenvectors now what
matrices have orthogonal eigenvectors
we're going back to linear algebra
because this is this is like a
fundamental fact to know this family of
wonderful matrices matrices with
orthogonal eigenvectors so tell me one
bunch of matrices that you know has
orthogonal eigenvectors symmetric and
what is special about the eigenvalues
they're real but there are other
matrices that have orthogonal
eigenvectors and we really should know
the whole story about those guys that
they're too important not to know so
what's another famine other-- bunch of
matrices so these symmetric matrices
have orthogonal eigenvectors and real
symmetric then the eigenvalues will be
real well what other family what other
kind of matrices have orthogonal
eigenvectors but they might be complex
and the eigenvalues might be complex so
and you just have to you can't know
Fourier without saying ok I can deal
with this complex number ok
so what's another family of matrices
that has orthogonal eigenvectors yes
diagonal for sure right and then we know
that we we have the eigenvectors are go
into the identity matrix right yeah so
we know everything about diagonal ones
you could say those are included in
symmetric now let's get some new ones
what else
orthogonal matrices count
orthogonal matrices like permutations or
like rotations or like reflections
orthogonal matrices and what's special
about their eigenvalues the eigenvalues
of an orthogonal matrix the magnitude is
1 exactly there has to be one because an
orthogonal matrix doesn't change the
length of the vector q times x has the
same length as x 4 for all vectors and
in particular for eigenvectors so if
this was an eigenvector q x would equal
the lambda X and now if that equals that
then lambda has to be 1 the magnitude of
lambda has to be 1 of course complex
numbers are expected here and that's
exactly what we're seeing here all the
eigenvalues of permutations are very
special orthogonal matrices I I won't
add permutations separately to the list
but they count now what so this has the
fact that this is on the list tells us
that the eigenvectors that we're going
to find are orthogonal we don't have to
do a separate check to see that they are
once we compute them they have to be
there are the eigenvectors of our
orthogonal matrix now I could ask you
let's keep going with this get the whole
list here along with symmetric there's
another bunch of guys anti-symmetric big
deal but those are important so
symmetric means a transpose equals a
diagonal you know a transpose equals a
inverse orthogonal matrices now I'm
going to put in anti-symmetric matrices
where
a transpose is minus a what do you think
you know about the eigenvalues for
anti-symmetric matrices
shall we take an example anti-symmetric
matrix say zero zero one and minus one
what are the eigenvalues of that well if
I subtract lambda from the from the
diagonal and takes a determinate I get
lambda squared plus 1 right equals 0 so
lambda is I or minus I that's a rotation
matrix itself yeah
yeah it's a it's a rotation through 90
degrees so there could not be a real
eigenvalue have you thought about that
or a real eigenvector if i rotate every
vector how could a vector come out a
multiple of itself how could I have a
transpose times a vector equal lambda
times a vector I've rotated it and yet
it's in the same direction well somehow
that's possible in imaginary in in
imaginary space and not not possible in
real space okay so so here's a lambdas
are imaginary and now finally tell me
you if you know the name of the whole
family of matrices that includes all of
those and more of matrices with
orthogonal eigenvectors so what is that
what are the special properties then
these would be matrices so I call them M
for matrix so it's a has orthogonal
you're vector so it's a Q times the
diagonal times q transpose that's well
I've really written down somehow I
haven't written a name down for them but
that's the way they way to get them I'm
allowing any orthogonal eigenvectors
sorry this is diagonal I've diagonalized
the the matrix and here the I get any
eigenvalue so I want to the final guy on
this list allows any eigenvalues any
complex numbers but there I can vectors
I'm want to be orthogonal
so that's why I have the Q so how would
you recognize such a matrix and what is
the name for them so that is so this
we're going beyond 1806 because probably
I don't mention that name the name for
these matrices in 1806 but I could and
anybody know it a matrix of that form is
a normal matrix normal so that's the
total list is a normal name
so normal matrices look like that I have
to apologize for whoever thought up that
name normal I mean like that's like okay
in a little more thought you could've
come up with something more meaningful
than just say normal oh god says matrix
that's the absolute opposite of normal
almost all matrices are not normal
so anyway but that's what they're called
normal matrices and finally how do you
recognize a normal matrix everybody
knows how to recognize a symmetric
matrix or a diagonal matrix and we even
know how to recognize an orthogonal
matrix or skew or anti-symmetric but how
do you what's the quick test for a
normal matrix well I'll just tell you
that a normal matrix has m transpose m
equal m m transpose I'm talking here
about real matrices and I really should
move to complex but let me just think of
them as real so if well the trouble is
they the matrices might be real but the
eigenvectors are not going to be real
and the eigenvalues are not going to be
real so really I I'm sorry to say really
again I should get out of the out of the
limitation to real yeah and how do I get
out of the limitation to real what do I
change here if M is a complex matrix
instead of a real matrix then whenever
you transpose it you should take its
complex conjugate so now that that's the
real thing that's the normal thing
that's the right thing yeah right right
things better okay so that's a normal
matrix and and you can check that if you
took that m and you figured out m
transpose and did that it would work
because in the end the queues cancel and
you're just have two diagonal matrices
there and that's sort of automatic that
diagonal matrices commute so a normal
matrix is one that commutes with its
transpose commutes with its transpose or
its conjugate transpose in the complex
case ok why did I say all that simply
because oh I guess that so the
permutation P is is orthogonal so so
it's eigen vectors which we're going to
write down in a minute are orthogonal
but actually this matrix C will be a
normal matrix I didn't see that coming
as I started talking about these guys
yeah so that's a normal matrix if I
because because circulant matrices
commute any two circulant matrices
commute C 1 C 2 equals C 2 C 1 and now
if C 2 is the transpose of so here's a
matrix yeah so these are matrices here
circulant Sall commute it's a little
family of matrices when you multiply
them together you get more of them
you're just staying in that little
circulant world with n parameters and
once you know the first row you know all
the other rows and so in fact they all
have the same eigen vector so now let me
that may be sure we get the eigenvectors
straight okay
okay I can vectors of of P will also be
I can vectors of C is because it's a
combination of powers of P so once I
find the eigenvectors of P I've found
the eigenvectors of any circulant matrix
and these eigenvectors are very special
and that's the connection to fourier
that's why we expect a connection to
fourier because we have something
periodic and that's what free is
entirely about okay so what are these
eigenvectors
let's take p to be four by four okay so
the eigenvectors are so we remember the
eigenvalues are lambda equal 1 lambda
equal minus 1 lambda equal I and lambda
equal minus I got four eigenvectors to
find and when we find those you'll have
a picture ok what's the eigenvalue
eigenvector for a lambda equal 1 1 1 1 1
so let me make it into a vector and the
eigenvector for lambda equal minus 1 is
so I want this shift to change every
sign so if I I better alternate those
signs so that if I shift it the one goes
to the -1 -1 goes to the 1 so the eigen
value is minus 1 now what about the
eigenvalues of
we're sorry the eigenvector that goes
with eigenvalue i so i'm looking i want
if i start it with one and i do the
permutation i think i just want i I
squared I cubed there and I think with
this guy with minus I I think I want the
vector 1 minus I minus I squared minus I
cubed so without stopping to check let's
just see the the nice point here all the
all the components of eigenvectors are
on in this picture all the here we've
got eight eigenvectors a Tigan values a
digan vectors the eigenvectors have
eight components and every component is
a power is one of these eight numbers
the whole thing is constructed from the
same eight numbers the eigenvalues and
the eigenvectors and really the key
point is what is the matrix of
eigenvectors so let's just write that
down so the matrix the eigen vector
matrix for all circulant s-- of size n
they all have the same eigen vectors
including including p all circulant c of
size and including p of size n which
where that's what we so what's the
eigenvector matrix what are the
eigenvectors well the first vector
is all one's just as their so that's an
eigenvector of p right because if I
multiply by P I I do a shift a cyclic
shift and I've got all one's the next
eigenvector is powers of W and let me
remind you everything is going to be
powers of W e to the 2 pi I over N
it's that complex number that's one inch
of the way round so that's C so what
happens if I multiply that by P it
shifts it and it multiplies by W or 1
over W double which is W transitive
which is another eigenvector okay and
then the next one in this list will be
well being going with W squared so it'll
be W fourth W to the sixth w to the
eighth whoa wait a minute so I get these
lined up right tell me your goes with W
squared up whoops
W squared now it's W the fourth W the
six W to the 8 W the tenth W the twelfth
and W to the fourteenth and you keep
going so that's the eigen eigen vector
with eigenvalue 1 this will happen i
have the eigenvalue it's either w or of
a conjugate might be the conjugate w bar
and you see this matrix so what would be
the last icon vector it would be w so
this is 8 by 8
I'm gonna call that the Fourier matrix
of size eight and it's the eigenvector
matrix so Fourier matrix equals
eigenvector matrix so I'm just what I'm
saying is that the linear algebra for
these circulant s-- is fantastic they
all have the same eigen vector matrix it
happens to be the most important complex
matrix in the world and its properties
are golden and it allows the fast
Fourier transform which we could write
in matrix language next time and all the
entries are powers of W all the entries
are in the on the unit circle at one of
those eight points and the last guy
would be W to the seventh w to the
fourteenth W the twenty first twenty
eight thirty fifth forty seconds and
forty nine so W of the forty-ninth would
be the last w tu7 squared it starts out
with W to the 0 times 0 all these are
the entry is yeah you see the picture W
xlix what is actually W xlix if W is the
eighth root of one so we have W to the
8th it's 1 because I'm doing 8 by 8 what
is W to the 49th power W it's the same
as W okay because W is a 48 is 1
right I take the sixth power of this and
I get the W 48 says one so W there 49 is
the same as W every every ever every
column every entry in the matrix is a
power of W and if in fact that power is
just column number times the room number
yeah
so those are those are the good matrices
so that so that is an orthogonal matrix
oh well almost it's not it has
orthogonal columns but it doesn't have
orthonormal columns what's the what's
the length of that column of that column
vector square root of eight right I add
up 1 squared eight times and I take the
square root I get the square root of
eight so so this is really it's a square
root of eight times an orthogonal matrix
of course the square base just a a
number to divide out to make matrix to
make the columns orthonormal instead of
just orthogonal but how do I know that
those are orthogonal huh well I know
they have to be but I'd like to see it
clearly why is that vector orthogonal to
that vector first of all they have to be
because the matrix is a normal matrix
normal matrices have orthogonal oh yeah
how do I know it's a normal matrix oh I
guess I can do the test if I have
[Applause]
if I have the permutation P I know that
P transpose P equals P P transpose
permutations commute so so it's a normal
matrix but I'd like to see directly why
is that why is the dot product of the
first or the zeroth eigen vector and the
next eigenvector equals zero let me take
that dot product 1 times 1 is 1 1 times
w is w 1 times W squares W squared up to
W to the seventh I guess I'm going to
finish that equals 0 well that's what's
that saying those numbers are the are
the are these points in my picture those
eight points so those are the eight
numbers that go into the that column of
that eigen vector why do they add to
zero how do you see that some of those
eight numbers is zero yeah the symmetry
would do it when I add that guy - that
guy W to the zero or W to the 8th or W
to zero
yeah when I add one and minus one I get
zero and I had these guys I get zero
when I add these these by pairs but but
what about a three by three so three by
three I'll go to W to the this would be
e to the 2 pi over 3 and then this would
be W to the 4 PI this would be W squared
e to the 4 PI over 3 and I believe that
those ads those three vectors add to 0
and therefore they're orthogonal to the
one-one-one
Argan vector because the dot product
will just bail just want to add those
three numbers so why is that true
one plus either 2 PI over 3 plus either
4 PI over 3 equals last minute of class
today we can figure out how to do that
well I could get a formula for that that
sum is 1 I could get a closed form and
check that I get the answer 0 the quick
way to see it is maybe
suppose I multiply by e to the 2 pi over
3 so I multiply every term so let's see
the 2 PI over 3 e to the 4 PI over 3 and
e to the 6 PI over 3 okay what do I
learn from this it's the same because e
to the 6 PI over 3 is is 1 that's that's
2 pi I so that's 1 so I got the same
someone Plus this Plus this this Plus
this plus one so I got the same sum when
I multiplied by that number and that sum
has to be 0 I can't get the same sum I
can't multiply by this and get the same
answer unless I'm multiplying 0 so that
shows me that that that also in the odd
when n is odd I also have that those n
numbers adding to 0 ok that's those are
the basic the beautiful picture of the
eigen values the eigen vectors being
orthogonal and then the actual details
here of what those eigen vectors are ok
good I hope you have a good weekend and
so we've just got a week and a half
left of class I may probably have one
more thing to do about Fourier and then
we'll come back to other topics but ask
any questions and that you'd topics that
you'd like to see included here where
we're closing out 1806 five while you
guys do the projects okay thank you